well we asked you to send in your
questions about tommy kronkovid variant
let's try to get some answers from our
expert panel who is with me tonight we
have professor jeremy brown professor of
respiratory infection at ucl and member
of the joint committee on vaccination
and immunization we also have professor
paul hunter he's an expert in infectious
diseases
and a professor in medicine at the
university of east anglia and dr sharon
raymond gp and director of the covid
crisis rescue foundation so you've been
busy sending us your questions
throughout the day we've got our first
question from katie now katie has
tweeted in to ask um
although the new variant is said to be
mild it is still much more transmissible
we were just hearing there the prime
minister confirming that so should we be
taking
more precautions uh dr sharon raymond
i'll come to you first
i mean i think we're in very uncertain
territory um and uh it remains to be
seen you know exactly what the impact uh
of vomicron will be in this country
we do know that it's uh very
transmissible and we do know that taking
precautions in the past has certainly
worked uh so i think you know what i
would encourage uh people to do is to
continue with the advice that we've had
so far
uh you know take the necessary
precautions uh think about social
distancing uh think about wearing face
coverings um and regular hand washing
good ventilation and if you've been
offered a vaccination please go ahead
and take it
well uh we have another question from
sarah who has text in to ask about the
self-isolation rules she says
fully vaccinated contacts have to
isolate if they have contracted the
omicron variant
but not
if it is delta so how do we know this is
a good question for everyone how do we
know which variant we have i'll come to
you first professor jeremy brown and i'd
also like professor paul hunter to
answer it so professor brown first
well the pcr test can differentiate
between the delta and the omicron
because there's two bands that come up
with the delta on the pcr but only one
band of the omicron so you can know if
you have a pcr test of course getting
the results the pcr test is not instant
so there's a gap where you may not know
whether you have omacron or delta
professor uh
hunter
yeah um absolutely right but i think
there's also additional information if
you know that you've been in contact
with somebody with
uh omicron then and you go down with
kobit that's a pretty good clue even
before you get get the results but
ultimately we
we are going to miss a lot of cases of
omicron because you know less than half
of people who get an infection already
with coved don't actually
come forward for testing so
we are
undoubtedly going to miss quite a few
cases of omicron
at the moment but
if you believe you've been in contact
with omicron or if you've been told you
or your contacts have been in contact
with omicron then treat it as such
should everyone then be taking a pcr
test regardless of what they think is
which variant they think they have
um
if people are symptomatic they should go
for um
for a pcr test the problem is that
increasingly
um
we are seeing there are asymptomatic
infections so somebody who's got an
infection may be
infectious but doesn't have any symptoms
won't even think about going for a test
and and if this is a more mild infection
then again the illness that you have
might not be quite as uh severe enough
to make you think yeah i should go for a
test so
it's it's difficult yeah it is difficult
uh let's move on then to a question that
came into our sky news inbox today um do
new variant symptoms differ from
previous variant variants uh are
sneezing and a runny nose symptoms of
omicron i'll ask you that professor
jeremy brown
yeah i'm afraid that you don't know i
have i don't think we've got clear data
about the clinical syndrome and
associated vomit compared to the other
variants at the moment unless somebody's
heard uh from the panel otherwise
i can't answer that question i'm afraid
that there's any obvious differences
between i think that is the problem
isn't it such early stages let me ask dr
uh sharon raymond what are you seeing in
terms of
symptoms if you are if you know that
someone has omicron
so i think it's very difficult i think
uh as uh colleagues have said you know
we at the moment you know there are
probably many people uh who do have
symptoms but we don't know you know
whether they've got omicron uh
so so it is you know it can be
challenging to distinguish but there are
a range of symptoms and we know that
there are a range of symptoms although
the most common ones are the fever uh
the cough the persistent cough and the
loss or change of taste or smell but
we're not necessarily it's not
necessarily what's reflected in the in
the findings in south africa but all
that remains to be seen in terms of what
the most common symptoms are with
omicron obviously you know i would just
say to patients to people uh you know if
you are experienced symptoms which may
be uh covered then please do get tested
and that applies also to household
contacts we need to have the pcr test
rather than the lateral flow test
okay um
another question that's uh brought in
from by email from sean uh straight to
the point is omicron more deadly than
other variants uh professor paul hunter
well it depends what you mean by that in
terms of an individual
person who gets infected probably not
and indeed the evidence from south
africa is that even after people go into
hospital
at the moment you when you uh when
people go into hospital they are less
likely to be more severely ill
then and become less severely ill than
people who um go in with say delta
but
that's um
translating that more globally and
particularly into
the uk setting is more difficult
even if the virus itself is less severe
and less deadly in an individual
if we have many more infections that
will still push up
the
incidence of severe disease and death so
um
i think uh
that's really what we desperately want
to know at the moment and it's still
going to be a few weeks away before we
can answer that
any more clearly than i've just
attempted
professor brown do you have anything to
add to that
yeah i mean you have to bear in mind
that the past
three four months rather unusually
i think the the incidence of infection
has been bobbling around about
well there's about a thousand deaths a
week something like that about five
percent of the beds in the hospital
occupied by people we've covered
and that's just about copa with we can
just about in the nhs deal with that
if you double the number of infections
then that will go up uh
and even if they're mild they'll put an
immense amount of strain on the nhs so
the real concern
is that actually just the sheer numbers
of people ending up in hospital if the
infection rate goes up in the community
will be a significant well a very big
drain on nhs resources and
take a lot of time up and
lead to a situation where we well it
could potentially lead to a situation
which we were in at the beginning of the
year where the hospitals have to
dedicate a very high proportion of their
of their resources to looking after
people covered even if the illness
illness itself is not as severe as it
was in january and the death rate would
be lower it could be a big issue for the
nhs
right um we've got a question from
sandra from
[Music]
give me a second and i'm coming to you
dr sharon raymond actually with this
question perhaps you can answer both at
the same time so
this struck me because actually we heard
so much about shielders right at the
beginning of the pandemic didn't we and
time and again we are reminded that
there are people out there who
could potentially really suffer at the
hands of various variants so sandra is
asking until more is known about the
efficacy of vaccines should people who
were previously told to shield be extra
careful i will ask you because
presumably that's a lot of your patience
dr sharon raymond
yeah i think probably at this time i
would say that that would be wise but
obviously each individual should take
the advice of their own gp
um you know in terms of their level of
risk and in terms of any kind of
additional steps they need to take um so
that's to be judged on a case-by-case
basis what i will say also in relation
to the previous question um is that uh
of course you know um
people being very sick and deaths are
one uh element of this but we need to
also be mindful of the fact that many
people who may even have quite mild
disease do go on to develop long covered
um and so you know that's why it's
absolutely you know crucial that we just
take the necessary uh steps uh to make
sure that people are adequately
protected that we protect ourselves and
by protecting ourselves but also
protecting others
um professor jeremy brown a question
that's coming to us on whatsapp why do i
need to isolate for 10 days if i am
double jabbed and boosted
yeah okay um
i guess the answer to that question is
that with omicron we don't know
how likely even after three vaccinations
you are
whether infection is still
like well the likelihood of getting
infection if there's a lot of infection
around it's still possible you that the
infection break through we expect that
after two doses omicron will be able to
break through that in quite a high
proportion of people and cause infection
mild infection mainly
after a booster we would hope that is
much reduced but it's still possible
unfortunately
we have uh had a message from ewan
stokes uh he's asking about the
government's travel measures uh i think
a lot of people have been querying these
haven't they over the last few weeks and
days it says with the new variant being
spread through
community transmission now as we know is
happening in the uk
what are the benefits of red listing
countries i think
that's fair i guess a lot of people are
thinking well hang on if it's already
within the community and that's how it's
being passed on why do we need to stop
people
coming into the country
that's that question before
it's a question for uh professor paul
hunter first i guess
right okay well yeah i mean the problem
with border restrictions generally is
that they don't last
very long they they never really stop
the spread internationally of infectious
disease although they can
delay the spread but once the infection
is indeed spreading within a country
then closing your borders has very
little additional benefit in reducing uh
in
the number of infections spreading in
the country
and indeed potentially as the world
health organization has pointed out
could have negative consequences because
you know the countries around the world
who
may in future get
new variants
might because of the fears of travel
bans and economic implications
then ultimately uh keep quiet about uh
the new variants that are occurring on
their patch and stop sharing information
which would be
very negative for the rest of us in
terms of controlling this pandemic
globally so personally i think um
i i would
see very little value in containing
continuing with border restrictions
uh professor jeremy brown do you agree
disagree will have something to add okay
so i think
when
when a variant is identified in a
country then the closing the border is
for two reasons one is to actually give
you time to get some information about
that variant whether it's an issue or
not and the other
is to try it to prevent spread
occurring from that country
and for you to establish whether that's
a significant issue now we're sort of
i i think i would agree with having put
in the travel bans initially while we
try and work out what's going on
but
once you know that the infection is
established in a country and spreading
rapidly within a country within the
community without being introduced every
time by somebody coming from abroad
then the benefit of maintaining the
travel ban at that point becomes
obviously much less
so it's a sort of thing that you have to
do when a new variant appears
but perhaps row back on at some point
when it's clear that either the new
variant is not an issue which actually
unfortunately omicron probably is an
issue
or
that the infection has now established
in your country
and by bringing in extra cases from
abroad it's not necessarily going to
stimulate the spread any faster now
we're in a game of a sort of
a speed game hit right so we need to get
the booster jabs in and they'll be in by
the end of january perhaps in the most
of the adult population who will be
accepting them
and if you could delay ombrecrom
arriving or causing a big wave until the
end of january anything that does that
is great the question is whether we're
past that point or not and i i have to
hand over to the epidemiologist to
answer that one because i know i don't
know where we are really
yeah it's an interesting insight isn't
it
to how these decisions get made and how
much you you have to weigh up um
from your position of expertise dr
sharon raymond om
from london has what zapped us to say
i'm a 17 year old that goes to college
and recently there have been four
positive cases near me and no one is
sure if it's the new variant or not it
seems to be spreading rapidly around the
school so what advice is given to
schools and should the entire class
isolate
um i think look
for each specific case uh you need to i
would recommend getting advice uh you
know calling 119 uh getting the relevant
advice making sure that people who've
got symptoms are tested um and there
will be public health advice in that
area for that specific school so i can't
really comment on the situation in that
specific uh school other than to say uh
obviously you know in communal areas
it's important in schools in general uh
to be wearing face coverings
and if there are cases uh which uh you
know there are people presenting with
symptoms uh covered like symptoms then
obviously people need to um you know
speedily get their pcr tests um and take
it from there in terms of getting advice
uh as to who should and shouldn't
isolate
professor paul hunter it's interesting
isn't it that this is a 17 year old
going to college worried about
how this how transmissible is we know
it's transmissible um more than delta in
fact do you think that there needs to be
a more nationwide more detailed uh
information and guidance for schools and
colleges
yeah i mean
i think in part
the the issue with omicron at the moment
is that we still don't know enough to
enable us to make
uh omicron specific advice um very um
forcefully uh compared to the other
variants but i i do believe that there
is a lot of advice around for schools
the the
government has published such advice and
it's available on on their website uh
how that changes with omicron i think is
still
how that should change with omicron is
still
unclear at the moment and hopefully in
the coming days we we will see
more uh
different advice and more focused
targeted advice because of the problem
with omicron but
it is still early days to be absolutely
sure what we should or shouldn't be
doing
okay um let's go to a question from mike
who's in norwich and he says if omicron
becomes a dominant strain will it help
build antibodies against more dangerous
variants uh professor jeremy brown i'll
go to you for that please
oh so the optimistic scenario and we
don't know whether this is going to be
true or not but the alternative scenario
is that omicron doesn't cause severe
disease therefore it's much less likely
to kill you
but can replace delta that does kill you
as the dominant variant in the country
and that would be a
sort of positive thing i suppose uh
but it's a it's a very optimistic
picture and i i suspect it's not going
to pan out quite like that and i suspect
that omicron is likely to cause severe
disease in susceptible people who are
not vaccinated
and those whose immune system means that
their response to the vaccines is weak
and they get breakthrough infections
despite being vaccinated even two or
three or even four times
so that's the elderly and those who have
uh immune diseases um
[Music]
so yeah there is there is an optimistic
sort of sonny uplands which could be the
case but it may not be the case in fact
most likely isn't the case
right thanks very much indeed we're
going to have to leave it there
professor jeremy brown professor of
respiratory infection at ucl a member of
the joint committee on vaccination and
immunization professor paul hunter
expert on infectious diseases and
professor of medicine at university of
anglia and dr sharon raymond gp and
director of the covid crisis rescue
foundation thanks very much indeed for
your insight and for answering all our
viewers questions thank you